[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast livestream our 21st am I correct
about that it's right here we're ready
to drink we are we don't have anything
to drink the water but no in any case
I'm here with dr. Heather hang and he's
not much going on this week so I think
it'll be more abstract we will discuss
high-minded ideas and not focus so much
on what's going on on planet earth
because frankly there just ain't much
I'd like to talk about the new findings
and obscure Natural History journals
interesting but I often want to talk
about and what I'd probably rather be
talking about but I don't think we're
gonna do it nope nope nope all right so
for those of you who are on planet earth
you know that we've just been kidding
around that there's a lot going on I saw
in the chat after the soundcheck before
this livestream I saw feedback coming in
from Germany Tanzania and Alpha Centauri
Wow which I regard as fascinating
because if this podcast is reaching
Alpha Centauri at that rate it suggests
Eric might be right there might be a way
to break the Einsteinian speed limit
which is good news because we have got
to get out of here yeah subliminal to
super little superluminal travel yeah
our way yes cool okay well without
further ado how about you lead us into
the breach okay well we were going to
begin by talking about whether or not
the events at Evergreen and of course
the other college outbursts Yale
Middlebury Berkeley all the rest
presaged the events that we're seeing on
the streets today and obviously by
asking that question we you know and we
you alluded to this last time that you
were beginning to see people say the
whole world is evergreen now
what we said in our last livestream was
yeah kind of
ish here a couple of ways that it's
different one being that there is a
clear instigating factor and another
being that George bridges and Trump are
quite different figures in terms of
would-be leaders but that doesn't really
get to the heart of the similarity does
it so I thought maybe we would start by
watching just a minute or so from the
third part of Mike Nina's excellent
documentary on what happened to you and
to us at Evergreen it's part three the
hunt individual Zach if you want to put
my computer on screen here I'll just
I'll play this and when I stop you can
pull us back okay
so apparently it's not working sorry
about this folks this is a live-fire
exercise we are doing our best to get
you some sound on this clip because
without sound it ain't gonna be nothing
no it really doesn't doesn't work
without sound well let's take one more
crack at it
we just oh that's super disappointing
okay so you could take that off sex oh
wow do you remember what you said I
remember roughly what I said what I said
was that I was frequently at the point
that this video is made asked to speak
on the question of free speech on
college campuses and then every time I
was invited on that topic I told them
the same thing which was this is not
about free speech and it is only
tangentially about college campuses the
college campuses were effectively the
first battle in something much bigger
and that this would eventually spill
over into the courts it had already
spilled over into the tech sector and
that if we weren't careful we were going
to see it spill over into leadership in
civilization and you know we can debate
til the cows come home whether or not
what we are seeing in civilization is
very like evergreen or something like
evergreen but the fact that it is
dawning on many people that what they
are seeing has some high degree of
relevance to what they saw in that
situation is on the one hand frightening
it means we didn't get the message in
time anin else is also reassuring
because it means that at least some of
the people involved are paying enough
attention even ones who are now
embarrassed that they had taken a
position that we were overreacting to
what we were seeing and experiencing
some of those people are now saying I
had it wrong yeah and as much as it may
be too late it's not obvious that it's
too late so there is hope in that there
is there is indeed so when we were
talking between livestream 20 and now
one of the things that was dawning on
both of us was that okay you know we we
both in you in particular you know more
than a year before Evergreen came to
public attention we're looking at this
and saying I I can see where this is
going I really hope I'm wrong I really
hope this prediction that I'm making is
wrong it turns out you weren't and we
weren't but this isn't about taking a
victory lap right this is about learning
from the model this is about learning
from the model that allowed you and us
to accurately predict that this was
actually what was going on in the first
place so I don't know if you want to
speak to that yeah I do I think in you
will recall from our personal
discussions when we first got our
initial glimpse of this that evergreen
or what's that every home that I was
hopeful that there was a possibility to
step into the situation and lead yeah
and it doesn't have to be me but
somebody needs to lead in order for this
not to turn into madness and anyway I
felt I'd been training for it in a sense
you know I had thought a great deal
about racism and studied the rudiments
of it scientifically speaking had great
relationship with a great many students
of every description and all of those
things seemed to me hopeful and so when
people heard me say in the hallway
during the initial public confrontation
that history could pivot in that hallway
if we could hear each other
I wasn't yes I didn't know that that's
what I was going to say but I was
tapping into a long-held belief that
something needed to take that energy and
turn it into something useful because
the frustration that fueled the protests
was real the complaint was phony so in
any case I think we're now seeing that
very same dynamic play out on the
streets of many major American cities
and the dearth of leadership is
spectacular and I think if people
understood what danger that creates they
would rightly be quite frightened about
what comes next
yeah so um so who should we should we be
looking to well a couple things one you
know as we discussed last time we have
an incredibly deep bench of really high
quality black thinkers in the West and
my concern is what we also seem to have
is a new model for how those people
interface with the public and it does
not look to me like a proper replacement
or upgrade for our past version of
leadership it looks to me like an
obstacle to it so the interface being as
I as I see it when I think of who we're
talking about and I came up with a few
more names in the interim but it's
there's some academics on the list and
then there are people who are you know
public intellectuals for lack of a
better term but the term that you would
use to describe to t'v how it is they're
making a go in the world is they're
their players in the gig economy as you
know as we are at this point so they're
trapped in the gig economy yeah and the
problem with the being trapped in the
gig economy is that the relationship is
producer-consumer which is not the
relationship of a leader to people who
are in need of leadership and so my
feeling is an actual leader truly needs
to be able to disappoint and to
dissatisfy in the short term for a
vision that if he's a good leader if
she's a good leader will do good in a
long term but you know a good leader
will also sometimes make errors and
short term there is a very good chance
that very many of the followers the
constituents whatever it is will not be
pleased and that has to be acceptable it
has to be acceptable I will say this is
also an echo of a dynamic that you and I
saw at Evergreen that had nothing to do
with the protests which was there was a
sort of creeping false sophisticate
among students that they were consumers
of education and that we were in some
sense their employees they were paying
good money to be there and we were being
paid to be there and therefore we were
their employees and we had some
obligation to deliver them what it was
that they wanted and you and I by the
end of it took great pains to point out
to them that this dynamic was not
correct that in fact I actually I
formalized this at the beginning of most
of my program was for the last five
years or so that we were there I don't
remember exactly I had sort of a script
to this effect and you know I never I
then never really saw it rear its head
at least in my in my programs but it had
it had a lot to do with you know I'm not
your employee
I'm not producing something for your
consumption I have knowledge and
expertise and things to teach you about
how to view the world how to understand
it and how to work for first principles
that hopefully you will find valuable
but we are all co-creating together I
bring to you curriculum that I have
created and then this this learning
environment will emerge as a result of
our producing it together you are not
consuming my thing and you are also not
paying my bills you know you are paying
money to a college and I am earning
money from a college but that does not
suggest an employer-employee
relationship yeah in fact many of the
things that superficially seem to be
accurate are not correct about the
interpretation so yeah you know we were
being paid by the state the state that
was being the education of these
students was being subsidized by that
state therefore the taxpayers were
paying to educate these people which was
not charity the fact is an educated
populace serves the state and so the
whole dynamic needed to be broken free
of the false analogy to a standard
producer consumer market relationship
and I think in some sense we have this
disease much more widely than we realize
because we are all of us increasingly
and the younger you are the more true
this is we are all being raised with
markets as
a dominant developmental influence and
so we learned to be consumers we do you
take on that mindset we forget that we
are citizens and we become consumers
instead our pseudo leaders treat us like
consumers they pander to us the way a
marketer it does and the thing is the
holy let children be advertised to right
which for which I have never heard a
rational defense I cannot I cannot
imagine why you would allow a
corporation to study the minds of
children and learn how to capture how to
make permanent dedicated consumers of
them yeah so in any case we we now have
this dynamic and unfortunately now what
we are seeing is the potential of this
mindset to disrupt leadership at a
moment when everything seems to be at
stake and as I'm sure we will end up
talking about I had a contact this week
somebody who has been following us for
quite some time
contacted me he's actually a Department
of Homeland Security officer in Portland
and he contacted me I think it's fair to
say in something of a panic based on
what he is seeing unfold
night after night for the last I guess
eight nights in Portland a standoff
between the protests and the police and
he frankly is worried about what might
emerge from this and among the
possibilities are you know a civil war
based you know in race and it wouldn't
be the first one of those obviously and
so I really think we have to figure out
how to escape the momentum of this
moment and without leaders I don't know
that we can do it which means I think
one of our primary concerns ought to be
figuring out what to do when your
leaders are trapped in the gig economy
how do you free them to actually do what
leaders are supposed to do mm-hmm
yeah well it seems to me that that is an
open question that we all need to be
thinking about
but the natural segue there was maybe to
to show some of the video that Andino
has collected actually so you met with
this homeland security officer yesterday
at the same time that I was having an
interesting interaction that's relevant
to the current moment that we'll talk
about as well with a totally different
human being and at the point that you
met with this man we had the impression
that while the protests had been clearly
quite destructive and divisive last
weekend in Portland that the curfew had
been had been dropped as of a couple
nights earlier and that things have
basically calmed down and this contact
this this guy and homeland security said
oh no really not which raises the
question why then did the curfew get
called off you know one thing we'd been
talking about as well was you know what
was what was the curfew for curfew
curfew sits badly but just about
everyone you know no one no one likes it
just like no one doesn't like no one
likes the idea of locked down even if
you can see why it has to happen one of
the things of course that curfew does is
it frees the police in I believe a good
way to say anyone who is on the streets
after this time is breaking the law and
therefore I can arrest you without
having to demonstrate anything else but
what it is that you're doing and
therefore you hopefully don't end up
escalating between police and protesters
or police and rioters into something
which could be much much worse
so the curfew has the potential to be
quite protective and it was on in
Portland for several nights running I
don't remember exactly how many but that
it had been called off and the second
night I think that it was not in place
we have we have these images actually
Zack if you want to play I guess just
the the first video that I showed to you
this is
Santino's twitter feed fan yes very
important
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah those peace signs are a little bit
ironic
so maybe switch and they're all sort of
pop up heaps but exactly to go to the
third video
so I think this is of the federal
building there two federal buildings
downtown the reason that Homeland
Security is front and center here is
that there has been a consistent attack
yes this is the Justice Center right
there so this is these are two federal
buildings that are being besieged by the
protesters the park that these
protesters riders actually I should say
since we can't hear the audio here I
don't know if anywhere will hear me talk
over this video all right I'll try to
yeah you want to take it off okay so the
standoff that is taking place there
disappears late in the night
the park is then cleaned up and the
buildings are thoroughly defaced with
graffiti if you've looked at my Twitter
feed you've seen some of the more
dramatic things that are sprayed they're
captured on on camera but in any case
these are buildings that the federal
government is charged with defending and
the rioters I think are clearly trying
to precipitate something that they see
as in their interest and my feeling is
it is exactly not in the interest of
almost anyone it's probably not in their
interest either for them to successfully
precipitate it but their power to
precipitate it is substantial and being
made greater by the municipal authority
in this case a weak executive which is
robbing them of tools that could prevent
lethal violence and so by if I may just
interrupt briefly Zak if you want to
hold on show me where to go here so this
is the letter signed by over a thousand
public health officials arguing that
while koban 19 kills racism predates
co-indictee
and kills more and therefore protesting
is a legitimate response to to the
current situation despite the fact that
lock downs are in place and still are
you know basically as of now so one of
the one of the things in this letter
I'll just highlight it and I can't
highlight it it's right when my cursor
is here there it is oppose any use of
tear gas smoke or other respiratory
irritants which could increase risk for
kovat 19 by making the respiratory tract
more susceptible to infection
exacerbating existing inflammation and
inducing coughing so that's that's all I
wanted to say there Zack that sounds at
one level like these public health
officials are trying to temper their
frankly ludicrous assertion that it's a
legitimate move to go out on mass under
the streets because this is a bigger
because the killing of the the senseless
and violent killing of one man at the
hands of a bad police officer is more of
a public health threat than open 19
that's that's a ridiculous statement
right now but in this they say well but
you know you don't want to inflame your
lungs sounds right and yet one thing
that you reported that this homeland
security officer told you yesterday
really puts this into stark relief I
think which is he said we're having our
tools taken away from us we're having
our our low impact tools like like like
smoke and even teargas taken away and a
virgin that leaves us with more and more
lethal tools yeah yeah so I should
probably say a little bit more and I
really I hope this was not said to me in
confidence I obviously wanted to talk to
me for a reason that had everything to
do with my public facing life I guess so
I'm assuming that I'm at liberty to talk
about this but he said a number of
things one is he said they're not going
to cede the federal buildings they can't
it's their mandate not to and the
federal officers yeah and that they are
fully capable of protecting those
buildings what they're not fully capable
of doing is protecting those buildings
and keeping the rioters safe
they cannot simultaneously do that so
the point is the rioters have a to
which is they can force these federal
officers into lethal violence which will
of course what do you imagine would
happen at this moment in the Georgia
flawed protests when lethal violence is
brought on protests protesters by
federal officers right this is
potentially shot heard around the world
stuff and in my opinion the anarchists
are actually looking for a massacre and
let me explain to you what I mean by
that because obviously the idea that
anybody would seek to be massacred is
ludicrous and it is ludicrous but you
have how many major cities engaged in
violent conflict on a daily basis now if
one of those cities sees a massacre it
does the job that the anarchists would
like right it will be used to illustrate
the illegitimate see and the
overreaction of of the government and so
if you have all of these anarchists in
all of these cities the chances that you
will be in the city where the massacre
happens are low so provoke provoke
provoke and probably it doesn't happen
where you are but it'll happen somewhere
and that's good enough and even if
you're in the city where it happens
chances that you are among the massacred
pretty low so there's a game being
played I believe in which the idea is to
precipitate violence that will be used
to justify what comes next and the point
is just as we all take a risk when we
get behind the wheel of our car thinking
it's very unlikely to be me that gets
killed there's an advantage to driving
so I'm going to accept that risk the
anarchists are accepting that risk of a
small risk of being massacred in order
to precipitate a massacre somewhere
which will do their bidding now the
problem is that the anarchists are
undercutting the legitimacy of the
actual protests that start at this
they've thoroughly undercut it already
and they are co-opting this movement for
what I regard is a completely insane
objective they actually believe that if
you
to our civilization down what would
replace it would be better now a we
might not survive it's being torn down
and be the chances that what replaces it
is better are very near zero here it's
just like it's like the argument that we
should terraform Mars because the
environment on the earth is lousy well
the environment on the earth is getting
worse it's always gonna be harder to
terraform Mars is you know is America a
fair place I don't think it's fair
enough I think we have real problems but
the chances that tearing it down is
gonna create a fair replacement no it's
gonna create a power vacuum and what's
gonna happen in a power vacuum is the
powerful are gonna rise you're gonna
make things far worse so the anarchists
don't have the right to push us into
this madness what they do potentially
have is the power and why do they have
the power they have the power because
somehow we have been led to accept a
world in which those who would lead are
doing something that sort of sounds like
leadership but it doesn't have the power
people can click away from from their
would-be leaders on the Internet where
they follow their leaders to useful
effect in many cases historically
speaking so how the heck are we gonna
bail ourselves out of the situation so a
small really tiny number of anarchists
don't lead the rest of us into a
conflagration that all will end up
regretting yeah I guess that raises for
me the question that we have been
talking about for years now of what are
the various constituencies that make up
the the people whom were seeing on the
streets right now and maybe you know as
as part of that related to that but not
exactly that question I'm also curious
as to you know really what what are the
data what it how much police brutality
is going on on the streets right now as
part of these protests and how much
right in rioting and looting and
violence by non police we can see
through these video feeds taken by some
whom we know and trust that in our
hometown there is violence and looting
and and rioting going on and I have
actually seen no evidence for police
brutality against protesters or rioters
here in Portland
clearly it's happening there are these
super cuts out there which are showing
only the awful behavior by the police
and there are super cuts out there
they're showing only the awful behavior
by the law by the rioters and what we
don't have is anyway I haven't seen
anyone with any even access to any even
like credible credible idea for how we
would know how we would begin to know
what fraction of the behavior that's out
there that's bad is being done by the
police and what fraction of behavior
that's bad is being done by the rioters
and looters and and and the violent
people who came for a fight and we also
don't know to what extent the
misbehavior of police is the result I
mean they are surrounded now by every
one of these walls that has been
vandalized literally calling for their
blood all cops are bastards is the
shallow end all right the graffiti goes
up into you know guillotining the need
for the police to pay with blood
pictures of pigs with X's for eyes
this is surrounding these people it is
intentionally there to make peace
impossible and this maybe we saw this at
Evergreen as well right so maybe before
we talk a little bit about what the
various groups of people are who are who
are protesting on America's streets
right now some of whom are good faith
and emotional and and really trying to
fix a system that is broken in some ways
let's speak a little bit to you know
what are but specifically your
experience was in a community having the
leader of the community stand down the
police who were good and honest and
honorable
and what kind of a vacuum that left sure
so for those who aren't familiar with
the story the I got a call Tuesday was
the day on which protesters showed up by
surprised that my class accused me of
racism demanded my resignation somebody
called the cops they came to check on me
thinking I might be in danger at that
point I didn't feel like I was in danger
although that would quickly change but
anyway they called the cops the
protesters who had not yet begun to riot
blocked the police so they couldn't get
in the building and check on me which
alarmed them but they stayed away they
went around to a different entrance to
the building rather than confront these
people who were obviously illegally
blocking them and then on Wednesday
following day I got a call from the
police chief Stacy Brown who I had met
the day before when she came to check on
me after the protest of my class I guess
I hadn't met her also at the four
o'clock meeting in the library but she
called and she said are you on campus
and I said no I don't have class today
she said good don't come to campus and I
said why and she said because we have
information that the protesters are
searching for someone
car to car and we believe it is you and
I said okay and she said what's more we
can't protect you the president has told
us to stand down and the police were
literally at this point locked in their
police station which left the campus on
governed and the lack of police on
campus had been a rallying cry on the
campus for years including amongst some
faculty some of the very radical faculty
and what then unfolded was instead of
the police the the protesters and
rioters formed what they called
community patrols they said they were
going to keep themselves safe since the
police couldn't do it and in less than
24 hours they were actually terrorizing
other students they actually physically
beat one guy
with weapons it took no time at all to
go from causing the power vacuum by
eliminating the police to you know
hunting people car to car they were
literally stomping traffic and nobody
was stopping them from stopping traffic
this is all documented and you know
intimidating people that's the result of
the power vacuum it's not the Utopia
that they claim is going to happen
some of them know that and they're just
looking for an excuse to behave this way
some of them are naive enough to think
that community patrols are going to be
an improvement justice wise lay your toe
pians some some of them the most naive
and good-hearted among them that
combination they even good-hearted are
utopians and they really think that if
you just get rid of the bad structures
that are already instantiated that good
ones will spring up like flowers you
know and of course that won't happen
well the the biggest irony I think of it
is that the bad ones the ones who
understand that it's not true are
actually about something so there's a
way in which the police are utilized to
leverage people who would otherwise
potentially revolt against a system that
has frozen them out of well-being the
police and police brutality are used to
keep people in line that's actually I
believe that to be true yep yes this is
no justification for bad policing right
but what happens when you pull policing
out is you get the community patrols
doing exactly the same thing in the
other direction they start bullying
people into making them more powerful so
it just it's just a paragraph where yes
the injustice is pointed in a different
direction it's animal form it is animal
farm and this is something that means so
I got into an annoying battle yesterday
on Twitter where I was pointing out that
many days anyone on Twitter well the
same battle on Twitter a little bit more
ferocious because what was it my point
was look you've got people calling for
us to abolish the police yeah I had I
found this one tweet this guy had 900
followers he had tweeted something about
abolishing the police
and it had almost a quarter of a million
likes now I have something like a
quarter of a million Twitter followers
the most liked thing I've ever said on
Twitter has maybe had 12,000 mm-hmm
likes this guy had a quarter of a
million likes on a tweet demanding that
we abolished the police and people good
people some of whom I know we're telling
me you're misunderstanding when they say
abolish the police they mean you know
rein in these growing police budgets
demilitarized blah blah blah blah blah
that's not what they mean they actually
mean abolish the police and it's a it's
one of these Mountain Bailey situation
exactly where they are they have a
almost responsible version of the
position and then they have their real
position and if you say hey that real
position is a dangerous downright CRAZY
yeah their point is well they want to
reign in the modern world dogs here come
on reining in budgets so anyway here's
the part people don't get when you say
abolish the police
can you imagine even if you thought that
was a good idea how much paperwork would
be involved in abolishing no that's not
my art here's my argument okay
no paperwork is involved in abolishing
the police because the structures to do
it are already there in civilian hands
and what you need is something that
forces those civilians to their worst
instance so George bridges the president
of our College was a civilian who just
happened to have the power to tell the
police not to enforce the law which
still shocks people when I tell them
that yeah why did the president of your
college have the ability to tell the
police not to enforce the law
well that wasn't my choice it was
somebody's choice deep in the past but
it unfolded on us as incidentally is
also true of the Portland Mayor Ted
wheeler has the ability to tell the
police not to enforce the law yes the
mayor of Portland is also the police
commissioner which means that the
ability to hog-tie the police is in his
hands already now it doesn't apply to
federal officers which creates a a whole
other dynamic where the city against the
part of our homeland security is here
which in terms is antagonizing the idea
that homeland security is in
the city is antagonizing the protesters
who seed the idea of federal officers
adds itself Anathem it's a democracy and
we know something about how wheeler
views this stuff because frankly he's
been bending over forwards to please
them since we moved here and before
right he is constantly keeping the law
from being enforced which emboldened
them to do ever more egregious things
including taking over intersections and
terrorizing citizens so maybe you know
maybe then to get back to this earlier
point lifting curfew why on earth you're
going to the protests are actually not
getting in any way better in fact
getting worse is curfew lifted and you
know I read some of the local news I saw
no evidence
I actually thought and a few other
people that I talked to that I guess
it's it's getting better is no curfew no
quite the contrary
why on earth that the curfew get lifted
on exactly the moment when Homeland
Security is here and fighting battles
every night with an increasingly
agitated crowd of sorry it's not the
protesters who are out there at 2:00
a.m. throwing buckets and bottles and
rocks yep a protester sets rioters yeah
it's rioters and you know this is a
distinction we have had to make
repeatedly with respect to evergreen is
there were protests they turned into
riots at the point they turn into riots
if you call them protesters you are
obscuring the nature of what's taking
place and you are obscuring the danger
that people are being put in so there
aren't there are good-faith protesters
out there on the streets let's and there
are there are you know the term that you
have tended to use and I agree with it
as anarchists at you know the other
extreme but there's also there are also
sort of people who are coming in and
doing you know not as much physical
damage not as much violence but maybe
putting the fabric of society at greater
risk who are basically bad faith
activists who have taken a good-sounding
ideology something like black lives
matter and basically wrapped up their
truly hateful ideas in that
and they are passing off their basically
hate filled ideology on to the majority
which is just confused about what it is
confused about what it is that we are
actually that that is actually being
engaged in so there's a natural tendency
you know look a lot of these people are
young yeah
protest has an honorable history it's
not entirely honor but it has also
necessary it's necessary it you know it
has all of the positive attributes so if
somebody can figure out how to connect
the dots for you so your frustration at
the lousy situation you find yourself in
or the boredom of ghovat nineteen or
whatever it is your frustration has an
outlet in which you can go tear some
some stuff up you know and feel like
you're making positive change then a lot
of people will fall for it a lot of
people will fall for it and it does you
know we we are not the first but we have
been saying for years that this has a
lot of the hallmarks of either religious
indoctrination or even worse a cult
right that there is that there is
cultish thinking that is being
encouraged among the among the good
faith young naive protestors who are
being you know and we see images I don't
have any queued up here but we see
images of people basically all being
forced to you know take a knee and put a
hand up and you know do all these things
in in in lockstep with one another and
then we're also seeing these children
these young adults being told that if
they don't force their the people who
are closest to them their loved ones to
disavow the racism at their hearts that
they themselves are racist and that
those people must disavow those people
those their family members that's that's
a hallmark of cult behavior right there
you separate people from their loved
ones you inform them that they can't
possibly be understanding the world
correctly and and then you have
basically an army that is ready to go
with you wherever you want it to go the
kists and that desire that destructive
desire that they have tapped into our
filling the leadership vacuum and so I
don't know I remember during an Occupy
the unnatural love for the idea of
leaderless nests and it came from
somewhere initially which was in the
past leaders had been a vulnerability of
movements and so a leaderless movement
negates that possibility right you
preclude a cult of personality we
include a cult of personality your
leaders can't be killed or co-opted or
whatever but you know it was clever for
two weeks and then it was really unclear
and it resulted in actually the
anarchist taking over the movement and
the fact is it became incoherent the
thing fractured become incoherent and
died yeah
what what had started as a legitimate
and widely hear Obul complaint about the
tarp program and the collapse of 2008
and the bailout who turned into just a
sort of unspecific complaint and the the
problem in this circumstance is I sort
of feel like we are watching occupy to
write that this is occupy it's the
unsustainable apart of that of Occupy
that took over in the end that has
suddenly come back and it's found a new
reason to be in the streets which is
George Floyd but that's not really
what's going on it's a general
frustration amongst people who basically
don't have the chops to figure out what
it is exactly they're complaining about
and so but they're also I mean that they
know at some level viscerally anyway
that they are tired of being told that
we live in the best of all possible
times you know this this is this is the
messaging coming from most of the sort
of intelligentsia and the media that you
know things are things are so much
better for for most of us by most of the
measures of resources than they have
been for any generation in the history
of the planet how could you not be
grateful and this I mean this is this
was like final point that I made in
those fourteen points and then in the
last live stream you know you've got
you've got a generation of P
Paul whose education have failed them
who are in debt who have terrible health
care who have almost no chance of ever
owning a home who have been drugged into
submission by legal pharmaceuticals in
many cases and who've been sold to all
of their lives such that the consumer
mindset is the one that they know and
they don't have the ability to regulate
their own psychological states in part
because they were being given drugs that
were explicitly about letting some
exogenous molecule regulate them for
them yeah of course they're angry and of
course they don't have the ability to
quite put their finger on exactly what
it is they're angry about because it's
kind of everything and also what are the
solutions it's it has to be systemic
there have to be sweeping systemic
solutions but it likely is not going to
be about frankly the idea of reforming
police departments which clearly needs
to be done some police departments need
perform not all of them I don't think
there's not police brutality widespread
in every single Police Department but
some police departments need reform but
that's not big enough that's that's not
big enough to solve the problems that
are true across America and
generationally no in fact the only big
Annelise problem is a symptom of a
different problem so if this protest was
actually sharpened to be about the thing
that generated the frustration that is
allowing it to happen it would be about
the system being rigged and even rigged
is wrong because rigged suggests that
this was all conscious when a lot of it
is a simple outgrowth of a corrupt
system serving those who have the
resources to take advantage of the
opportunity for corruption which has
generated a positive feedback for wealth
and power that has frozen a lot of
people out and so that frustration about
the system being rigged actually comes
with a a corollary involving the police
which is if you are going to rig a
system against people and they are not
going to revolt the reason that they are
not going to revolt is because the
penalty for running afoul of the police
is high so bad policing is a feature not
a bug right it's part of how the corrupt
civilization
and keeps people in line when actually
they have a very good reason to be angry
and to say so and you know I would also
say that our absolutely massive
unmatched anywhere else in the civilized
world prison system is yeah is the same
phenomenon which is it's cheaper Frank
as expensive as our prison system is and
as expensive as our highly military
militarized police are it is the cheap
solution to a different problem which is
how do you freeze people out of well
being that they would be entitled to
participate in and not have revolution
right so anyway that thing requires a
solution not at the police level I'm not
arguing frankly it may be that we've got
the wrong model of police it may be that
actually a from the ground up rethink of
the police makes sense in in tandem with
a rethinking of how we can bring
everyone in on opportunity now mind you
I did not say anything about
distribution of wealth because
distribution of wealth is a symptom of
the distribution of opportunity problem
and if we talk about the distribution of
wealth problem we are gonna end up in a
quagmire we can't get out of but the
distribution of opportunity problem any
honest broker should acknowledge that
opportunity should be widely distributed
right freezing people out of opportunity
does not serve us the market does not
function well when people do not have
access to it so distributing opportunity
widely is the thing that we ought to be
fighting over is it why are they
distributed if it is okay but if it's
not and it sure looks to a lot of us
like it's not that's something to talk
about and then this the police issue is
downstream of it right now is there a
racial component to the police thing I
think we all know there is is it as
clear-cut as black people are being
gunned down in the street by the cops
and it's happening all the time and you
know well frankly that analysis doesn't
stand up when you look at the actual
statistics
yes it's disproportionate but it is not
it's not the problem that is singularly
experienced by the black community it is
a problem of bad brutal policing that we
see too often in every community blacks
are running afoul of the police at a
high rate why I would argue it has a lot
to do with being frozen out of
opportunity which results in more
lawlessness we can debate whether that's
actually the cause but sure looks right
to me and anyway it is a systemic
problem but what do you do when the
people who are apparently protesting at
the frustration are also you know
massively looting are claiming that all
cops are you know so guilty of this that
they deserve death without a trial I
mean this is such a dehumanization on
both sides and that will only make the
problem worse both sides it has become
easy for and you know you can you can
draw lines in a lot of places so a lot
of these things have it both sides
there's a police versus rioters there's
a left versus right you know blue states
versus red states there are many places
to draw the lines and in both cases what
we see as things get tenser and tenser
is those people over there aren't really
quite humans anyway are they and no one
is saying that out loud
exactly but it's it be kit is becoming
the tenor of the conversation so one
thing you said back there prompted me to
think let this thing this thing that is
easily mocked in conservative circles
that it seems like progressives don't
believe in meritocracy like you they
don't even want merit to be the basis on
which advancement is made and things
like school and jobs and you know I have
thought this is an absurd is it absurd
critique what what the hell of course we
have of course we want a meritocracy but
your points there about
about how opportunity has been
distributed not equally means that we
can have the appearance of a meritocracy
without there actually being one because
opportunities have not been distributed
equally early enough for people who are
now adults to have all of the skills
that they would have had had they had
the opportunities that they should have
had by an actually equal Society
so of course meritocracy is what we what
we want what we should have you know
arguing for anything else gets us into
Harrison Bergeron territory the the
Vonnegut short story that you've
referenced before but in order to have
an actual meritocracy we have to have a
quality of opportunity throughout
society and as earliest ages as possible
for for children who would otherwise be
effectively sidelined from the you know
sidelined from the American dream among
other things
well I of course agree with everything
you just said the problem is that again
as I think a result of a lack of real
leaders empowered to do what leaders do
we have an artificial bifurcation of the
positions leaving two wrong ones right
so on the right we have a position that
is correctly in favor of meritocracy and
frankly the inequities that would be
produced by it naturally in other words
some people contribute more and some
people contribute less but on the right
that is fused together with a belief
that things are much fairer than they
actually are and so you know declaring
it's a meritocracy at the finish line is
not quite acceptable if what's happening
at the starting line is that people are
you know discovering that somebody has
you know strapped them to the starting
blocks and you know put up barriers in
front of them and yeah okay you cross
the finish line later but it wasn't
inherently about merit so so that's
what's going on on the right is a belief
that things are fairer than they
actually are and a kind of
rationalization of the unfairness that
is there but it's maybe a little hard to
diagnose and then on the left there is
this attack
meritocracy which the first time you
hear it you think this must just be some
little outbreak of insanity in this room
and then it turns out now it's actually
widespread everywhere yeah and it really
comes with the deindividuation at the
point you surrender you surrender the
idea that I am responsible for
achievement right I am better off
becoming part of a mob than I am being
an individual responsible for my own
achievement then this all begins to make
sense the point is well the mob will
achieve something and then will divide
it well you know what's gonna happen
when the mob achieves it it's gonna to
be divided so unequally alright if you
think you think the mobs gonna be
equitable alright really that's that's
really the question if you think the mob
is gonna be equitable you don't
understand the game theory that
underlies mobs they're taking advantage
of you in order to get where they want
to go and as soon as they do they'll cut
you loose which is of course what
explains this phenomenon that everybody
is now remarking on about the left
eating its own right right the left eats
its own because it is too prone to D
individuation and mob like behavior and
when the spoils are there to be divided
they're divided the way human beings
would be expected to divide them in the
absence of a system that aspires to
fairness yeah that's right boy there's a
lot there's a lot more to say here maybe
I let me talk just for a couple of
minutes about what I was doing while you
were meeting with the homeland security
officer sure so I have I have gotten
approval to use her name he'll say I was
approached by the mayor of Mill Valley
California a woman named Sachi McEntee I
hope I'm pronouncing your last name
correctly Sachi who Mill Valley is a
town of about fourteen thousand a few
twelve fourteen miles north of San
Francisco in Marin so for people who
don't know California Marin County is is
quite wealthy pretty white and and this
is effectively a bedroom community of
San Francisco in the Bay Area it's
beautiful it's on the you know east
eastern slopes of Mount Tam Mount
Tamalpais
um and Sachi who I did not know at all
before she approached me a couple of
days ago and we spoke for a while
yesterday is being dragged you know it's
being facilitated by the Twitter mob but
it is happening in her hometown now
because in a you know in a zoom call boy
I'm probably gonna get the particular
details a little bit wrong here but they
were doing a city council meeting I
presume because they were still in
lockdown just within the last week or so
and there was an opportunity for
community comment but you know they
we're all following that you know City
Council rules are whatever they are it's
not Robert's Rules of Order but it's
something there's they have to follow
some rules about what they do and do not
talk about and during community comment
a question came over the transom it was
something to the effect of I had a black
lives matter sign up and it got taken
down and I wonder what you the mayor of
and the City Council in Mill Valley are
doing to ensure that black lives matter
something like this and saw she
responded according to protocol but
perhaps she allows a little bit more
tersely than might have been perfect for
the situation it is a matter of policy
that we don't comment on things that are
not of local or immediate importance in
city council meetings that is the extent
of her infraction that is that is the
infraction that now has had protesters
with signs and a flyer and they were
going to be marching on her home and
they were calling for her resignation
and they were informing people far and
wide about her hatred of all things
black lives matter and what I haven't
said is that Sachi herself is a person
of color see she's a Sri Lankan American
she's not black she's not African
American it's different but it's not
that she has not experienced the you
know the racism that does still exist
and you know
in America herself as someone who is you
know a politician in a town in
California and has has done good work
and people people have honored that work
until now but she is now in this
position of I don't I don't know how to
respond to these people and she clearly
is compassionate
she is so humane she happens to be a
Republican they are now picking up on
that and saying Ah she's been hiding the
fact that she's a Republican no actually
you elected her to be mayor knowing full
well that she was a Republican and you
voted her in in this you know pretty
liberal County in in the liberal state
of California knowing what her politics
were but also knowing that she cares
deeply about people about the community
about leadership and about doing right
by her constituents so so I want to stop
us from doing something yeah it sounds
like she's a marvelous person if she
doesn't need to be that's right she
could be that's right an average person
in this case and what is going on is
still obvious and let me point out that
I actually can I just interrupt there
and so it's it's exactly the it's
exactly the instinct that has people
explaining how lovely a rape victim was
right it doesn't need to have been true
right or you know yeah George Floyd's
case yeah turning him into a saint
rather than just the victim of a crime
yeah good so anyway what I would say is
look you cannot we've already talked now
about the fact that there's a game
theoretic reason that you might have
anarchists looking for a massacre
against themselves right there's a good
reason because it advances the anarchist
ball we can see what is taking place
with Sachi mm-hmm in what happened at
Evergreen it's a story I think we told
last time on on the podcast but the
flyer gate story is the flip side of her
story so at the flyer gates story at
Evergreen a flyer for a rally against
white supremacy at Evergreen and there
was no wipe supremacy of Evergreen
so flyer advertising a rally against a
fictional enemy was put up but welcome
to have the rally but turn okay no big
deal but I had you know it had black
power symbols on it but you know I saw
the flyer it struck me as odd that they
were protesting white supremacy because
I couldn't figure out what they meant
but you know I wasn't angered by it I
was just perplexed but some people may
have been angered in any case some
fliers were taken down we think we don't
know the person who announced that they
were taken down turned out to be a bad
actor so maybe that was even cooked up
but let's say the Flyers were taken down
by somebody who was rubbed the wrong way
by a black power rally against white
supremacy at Evergreen okay at the point
that Naima showed the poster and
described how exhausted she was for
counseling students about the trauma
they had experienced that their posters
being taken down the school erupted in
an outpouring of the most absurd support
for this anti white supremacy movement
where literally the administrators of
the college were all posting this flyer
against white supremacy at Evergreen on
their doors the day care center was
printing the fliers up right and it was
just it was madness as people fell all
over themselves to advertise that they
were definitely against all of the white
supremacy at Evergreen ogor than thou
right I am low credit now so the point
is all of those people were solving a
problem for themselves at expense for
other people who did the expense fall to
it expel to those of us who wouldn't do
it who weren't going to pretend that
something was going on at Evergreen that
wasn't so it's externalizing harm onto
others to solve your own little problem
this is why we're worried about Ted
wheeler and what he's gonna do to the
police in order to advertise to the mob
that he's really with them and what
happened to Sachi was that she made that
she made the Cardinal error of not doing
what was being demanded of her she was
supposed to she was supposed to
advertise Failte mm-hmm she didn't do it
and now she has to be publicly punished
so that the next person that they ask
will demonstrate fail T and that is
really the key to this whole thing is
that the way to
willpower is to get each person to solve
their own problem and externalize the
harm on to those who won't do it and
then the whole thing topples and it's
it's very tough right so how you know a
politician one of the things that a
politician should be doing is receiving
and hearing the fears and the anxieties
and the concerns of their constituents
and basically reflecting those back in
such a way that they that that the
politician can assure their constituents
I hear you and I have both the power and
the intention to help those things get
better all right like that is part of
what a politician is supposed to be
doing and so there is potentially a
reason that an apology for something
that that wasn't wasn't an error was
necessary and you know she and I went
back and forth on this a little bit you
know and my point was never make an
apology that you don't mean because we
need apology we need apology in the
world we need good apology we need
honest apology and if we weaken that if
you start having people make apologies
that they don't mean then then we lose
this incredibly necessary tool in human
interaction and and you know it's it's
not it's not just human we obviously
don't have apologies by words and
dolphins and chimps and elephants and
such but we have you you see clear signs
of forgiveness and affiliation and
reconciliation such so you know I I
preface those comments to her with I'm
not a politician I don't fully
understand how it is that you need to
reflect back those fears and anxieties
to your constituents and make it clear
that you heard them but certainly I
would say to not make any attempt to
appease do not make any attempt to
appease because there will be no
appeasement they will they they will not
be appeased uua you did nothing wrong
and in my view I'm not sure that she
would say that but in my view she did
nothing wrong she did nothing wrong do
do not you know do not try to appease a
mob
you know don't don't negotiate with the
terrorists well do not try to appease a
mob they will not be appeased and then
they will just be one step closer to the
the leadership that they certainly
shouldn't be in I mean you know we
this with George bridges who you know at
the point that he acknowledged his
internal racism right which is it's a
lot wrong with George bridges I don't
think racism is anywhere in there yeah
but at the point that he acknowledged
the racism that the crowd demanded that
he acknowledge they turned on him and
they were like aha we told you you were
a racist and it was like whoa you just
insisted that I admit it and you know so
anyway yeah the you don't you don't fess
up to thought crimes right the best you
can do is you can speak the truth and
the thing is if you are cast out you are
going to be cast out into the realm of
those who also stood up and I can't
promise you that it's gonna work out
okay I don't know what's gonna happen
but I can say if the problem is they're
driving you crazy by demanding that you
admit things that you are not guilty of
than being cast out into the realm of
others who stood up will be a breath of
fresh air that I can tell you yeah okay
well there's at least a one what one
thing for sure else that we want to talk
about and maybe maybe quickly too and
one of them is to return to something we
talked about last time
so I began the last last livestream in
these fourteen points and I raised the
issue of in Donald Trump's June first
press conference he mentioned the Second
Amendment and I had this reaction of
what the hell was that doing there and
it wasn't that I was objected to him
talking about the Second Amendment at
all it just really didn't seem to belong
in that sentence and I asked was that a
call to arms and if so I suggested that
that was possibly treasonous I didn't
say it was it called arms but I you know
that that was that was my one of my
guesses and maybe my best guess at the
time but we have a friend who grew up in
the south who had a different take and
I've heard versions of this from a few
people but I'm actually just gonna read
this friend's take on this and then have
us talk about these I actually as soon
as I read what she wrote I thought yeah
I think this is a much a much more
likely and valid interpretation of what
he was doing
it was a call to arms so she says men on
the South Christian men in particular
literally talk all the time about how
one day the government will show up to
take their guns away and that will be
the day that they defend their families
as men of God should do if there was
ever a time that I was around more than
two adult men and that top it didn't
come up I swear to you I have no memory
of it I think what Trump was actually
saying to his base was you may have to
see tanks in the street but it's not the
day you have been dreading your Second
Amendment rights are safe under me
amazing amazing right and and so we then
the three of us had sort of a back and
forth and do you want to riff you a
little bit well yeah I do one thing I
would say is this mirrors quite well
what I heard from the department of
homeland security officer and one of his
major concerns is that the rural folks
are watching the cities go insane and
they you know are heavily armed as a as
a demographic and they are being called
upon effectively to not take up arms in
this conflict which is very important
that they don't at this moment because
this could easily break down into
something from which we cannot emerge
and he also helped me to understand this
concept that many of us have started to
hear some people will be thoroughly
familiar with at boogalou which I've
been told all kinds of things about it
being code for race war and all of this
what he told me and what I've seen
reflected elsewhere and I am in no
position to say for sure what the truth
is but so hard to figure is that it is a
code word for the day that the
government comes to relieve the
population of its guns and in any case
the
fact that that is expected to happen is
an important fact in this discussion
that everybody needs to make eye contact
with mm-hmm I think there's another fact
that everybody needs to make eye contact
with which is gonna be especially
uncomfortable for people on the left
which is I believe the reason that this
the set of riots has not spilled over
into neighborhoods that it's been kept
to government buildings and commerce
establishments is that the population at
home is armed at an unknown level that
is to say there are a lot of guns that
people have in their homes and they are
also in many places in a position to
defend their homes with those guns and
not go to jail for shooting somebody so
in any case I know that inside of gun
circles there's a lot of discussion
about what the circumstances are that
actually justify you using overwhelming
force to to end an invasion of your of
your property in other words inside your
building for example yeah and so I have
the sense that one of the things that
the left needs to own up to is that to
the extent that it is quaking in its
boots about these riots spilling over
into neighborhoods that although the
Second Amendment was not written to
protect from this moment it may in fact
be protecting civilians from being
confronted by this frankly very
dangerous mob and that at some level
somewhere in our Second Amendment
discussion that fact needs to be lodged
yeah now that's that's that's critical
and just one one last thing on this one
of your reactions when we first heard
this from our friend is that the Second
Amendment isn't there isn't isn't about
the guns it's not you know we shouldn't
care about the Second Amendment in order
to protect the guns the guns are there
in order to protect our other rights and
you know we talked about this a little
bit last time I think it was in the Q&A
you know someone said you know - and
then the Second Amendment is just as
important as the first and we had a
little back-and-forth on this and you
know at first I said yeah of course and
you kind of
pushed back and I think yeah you know
actually the second is what allows us to
defend the rights that are laid out in
the first and I actually I just printed
out what the first says it's so it's
it's actually a a beautifully complete
sentence and it's it's short Congress
first amendment Congress shall make no
law respecting an establishment of
religion or prohibiting the free
exercise thereof or abridging the
freedom of speech or of the press or the
right of the people peaceably to
assemble and to petition the government
for a redress of grievances and one of
the things that is so beautiful about
that all all of those things which might
under some ad which all of those things
which might under some really bad
circumstances need to be defended
perhaps by by someone who was
appropriately armed is that it begins at
the most private thing you know freedom
of religion that which only you know
that's between you and your God and it
need never go beyond your own head and
it goes out from there it's it's
religion or the exercise of religion or
speaking about religion or speaking to
the press so that they can share what it
is and you know and now we're beyond
religion its ideas the right of people
to then group in numbers and to and to
approach the government and to get them
to redress grievances it just goes from
the most private to the most public it
takes on all the levels of democracy and
you know points once again to how just
brilliant and foresight at the founding
fathers of this country were but of
course they couldn't have known most of
the technology that we're living with
now which is part of what those of us
you know on the left who understand the
necessity of the second amendment are
talking about when we say okay but there
have to be some limits yeah it is a
beautiful document I mean it has its
paradoxes in and I saw the third
amendment to come up trend it on Twitter
the third amendment that was an amazing
moment because it's the soldiers are
coming I think they were kicked out of a
hotel or something but in any case so
I've taken the left to task here for
a naive interpretation of the Second
Amendment and its relevance to the
present I think I should say on the
other side there is the question of
whether or not any of the amendments
other than the second would be defended
with the guns that are protected by the
second and I have concerns that actually
one of the things that is unfortunately
true is that the only right that would
result in the founding fathers hedge
against tyranny that they built into the
Second Amendment being utilized is a
challenge to the Second Amendment yeah
so anyway I think that means a rethink
if I can close us out here with a final
thought do you have something maybe
we'll come back in a later episode but I
just want to say that as many people
will know there was a big paper there's
a big retraction from The Lancet
yesterday the day before Lancet being
one of the major medical journals and as
being an article that you know had gone
through peer review that found that
hydroxychloroquine was not only not
effective but actually possibly
dangerous in the treatment of covin 19
and so it got you imported widely and
and it's it was it was mostly stopped as
I understand it in many places but it's
been retracted because the data were bad
and you know one at one of the takes is
well but peer review never pretended
that it could see whether or not the
data were bad it's whether or not the
analysis is bad and that's true
but it points further to the rot at the
core of of what is going on in science
and medicine right now and not not at
all what you know a problem with how it
is that we can understand what is true
using the scientific method but you know
if people are willing to fabricate or
just find a lousy data then of course
you can't trust anything downstream with
those decisions yeah amazing that there
is a retraction of this sighs out of
this journal on this topic right now and
I think it was episode six that we
talked explicitly about peer review and
some of its problems well here we have
further evidence of that so yeah
as if we needed further evidence but
here it is alright so what I wanted to
close with was something that this DHS
officer said to me among the many things
that struck me actually he said two
things that I think are worth saying he
said that he thought Trump had been
elected as a giant middle finger to a
system that was broken and I resonate
with this I agree that that's why he was
elected but he said he's very much the
wrong person for the crises of 2020 and
I thought that was a very interesting
piece of nuance I hadn't heard from
anybody but even more importantly he
said something to me which I know that I
have said I may even have said it on
this podcast which is that all cops are
bastards could rightly be replaced with
SCA be some cops are bastards so here
you have a person charged with defending
a federal building afraid that he is
going to be lured into massacring people
that he very much does not want to shoot
at acknowledging that in fact there is a
problem and that some cops are indeed
bastards and I was struck I mean I was
actually as he said it I was in view of
all of this graffiti where people are
saying you know all cops must die and
this other just stuff with you know it's
the opposite of nuance and the
difference between somebody who is
nominally on one side of this who is
able to acknowledge exactly the thing
that I would want acknowledged which is
that there is a problem right and then
the other side is so busy trying to pick
a fight in fact it doesn't want the new
one the nuance is the thing that will
prevent what they are looking for what
they are looking for is a conflagration
and all of us on the outside of that
little narrow fight are in some sense
stuck in the middle because if they get
their conflagration it's all of us who
are going to lose and I don't care what
neighborhood you live in I don't care I
mean I don't mean I don't care I care
but no matter how bad your policing is
the absence of policing will make it far
worse the lawlessness in you know the
worst neighborhood in America the
lawlessness that will happen if there's
no law
is much greater so in any case let us
please figure out how to resurrect the
concept of leadership so that somebody
wise is in a position to tell people you
know what that stuff doesn't speak for
us we are over here that's something
else don't listen to those people very
good alright so we probably want to say
a few words about we will be taking a
break for 15 minutes and coming back and
taking your super chat questions as we
usually as we always have starting with
the super chat questions from this hour
and then picking up about halfway
through with the super chat that comes
in the next hour but we won't be back on
Tuesday with a live stream because
you've got something else in the works
yeah I've got a podcast that I recorded
yesterday I don't know how much I should
say about what's in it I say who just
yeah sure
Yuri Deegan who I blew it you did it I
did it it's Yuri Dagan who is the the
guy the entrepreneur biotech
entrepreneur who wrote the excellent
medium article basically a review
article of the evidence relevant to the
question of whether or not Kovach 19
might have been started by a laboratory
leak of a virus that had been studied in
Wuhan anyway excellent interview I think
you will find it fascinating I will
release it on Monday and I think so it's
it's a couple of hours and you were
talking about doing it as what's called
a premiere so I might I have to figure
out whether Yuri could join me for that
so you could mean maybe maybe you know
if there's a possibility for feedback if
even if it were just you yeah
as I understand it I don't know but as I
understand it it allows for some of the
virtues of a live stream on YouTube
virtues and the horrors exactly they're
inextricably tied up together but
basically you you if you did that then
you would be online and you would be
answering superjet questions and texts
just as if I'm dodging super tech
questions we don't know yeah we don't
know bullets yeah and then uh
and then you may have another one we'll
just we'll leave that sir vague
after that there's any and it's gonna be
a good one and we don't know you know
maybe in between those two we'll come
back for a live stream but we'd but the
the timing is going to be different
starting now also Zack our producer and
just finished tenth grade son how does
the last day of school yesterday so we
could start doing these earlier even on
weekdays for those in Europe who have
been asking for that so I feel like
everyone in Europe has been asking for I
think so yeah that's that was my
understanding too okay that's it for now
so great please like subscribe comment
and consider spreading this video around
if you got something useful out of it it
would be great to reach some people who
don't even know that there's a
discussion taking place we will see you
in 15 minutes to answer your questions
in the meantime stay safe
you